hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science here I've had a lot of questions
about my skincare and makeup routine so
today I'm going to be showing you my
morning routine my evening routine is
much more complicated and much more
variable so I thought I'd start with the
morning routine which is a bit simpler
and then maybe show you guys my evening
routine a bit later I'm not a makeup
artist I have no idea what I'm doing
with my makeup so I'm probably doing
like 20 things wrong but this seems to
work for me and it's good enough so I'm
sticking to it
my skin is really dehydration prone so
in the morning I've rinsed my face with
water without using cleanser and Pat it
dry with a towel I try not to use too
much under my sunscreen so I usually
just use some sort of hydrating spray or
tone on I've been using the rush
possessory sink for summer but I think
I'll have to switch to something more
humectant when dry winter weather comes
around a lot of people have asked me how
I apply my sunscreen so here it is my
favorite sunscreen of all time is ultra
suta khals ultra UV protective
moisturizer it's light it's not white it
sinks in easily so you can apply lots of
it without any issues it doesn't clog my
pores and it has tea no salt s which is
my favorite UV a protective ingredient
it also isn't silicon heavy which is
pretty rare with sunscreens designed for
daily use I personally find that
silicones make my skin really oily after
a few hours it also doesn't sting my
eyes so I can put it all over my face
without any issues
I know it's really expensive but it is
really good I'm working on some reviews
of some more affordable sunscreen
options so keep an eye out for those I
use around 3/4 of 1/4 TSP as I worked
out when I put tape all over my face and
I try not to rub it in too much I have a
few other videos on how to wear
sunscreen so it's as effective as
possible and I've linked them below in
the caption then I wait around 15
minutes or so before I apply foundation
so that my sunscreen has time to set and
it won't shift as much usually at this
point I'd go off and do my hair and put
on my clothes but for this video I
decided not to be naked
and my has already done next I apply
foundation I have a few foundations that
I use a lot but I'm often just testing
out different products so it isn't
really set I'm blending together l'oreal
infallible pro glow in creamy natural
designer brands luminous hydrating
foundation in porcelain ivory and
nourish london illuminating face shimmer
I used to use matte foundations because
my skin is oily but I found that during
the day I'd get oily and patches and it
looked really obvious mixing an
illuminator into my foundation pretty
much fixed that my skin does get oily
but the contrast between the dry and
oily patches isn't quite so blindingly
obvious I found out that I can't
actually use this L'Oreal foundation two
days in a row without breaking out which
is a real pity because it has such a
gorgeous finish so if it works for you
I'm super jealous I'm patting the
mixture armed with a dab eco tools
sponge and trying not to rub so the
sunscreen doesn't move around too much
I'm really not a morning person so the
sponge is really handy since it doesn't
require too much brainpower and I can
sort of just slap myself in the face
with it I'm currently using it cosmetics
bye bye under-eye illumination concealer
and medium
I usually don't use too much concealer
under my eyes because it always creases
on me and makes me look even tighter
tired or wall tired then if I just let
my dark circles hang loose but I use it
everywhere else on my face as well I
like using my finger for concealer
because I find it easier to control than
a brush plus it means I have less
brushes to wash
next up is powder I use the stash base
powder after a lot of trial and error I
found that the best powders for my oily
skin have stashes their first ingredient
I'm using Joe leeks rose silk finishing
powder with a fluffy brush from Ecotools
sometimes I actually mix regular grocery
cornstarch into it if it's going to be a
hot day and I need more oil control I've
seen a few things online about how you
can't use cornflour because it's not
specially treated or whatever but you
can use it safely
I have a blog post on it that I've
linked so you can read all about it
the next step is blush and highlighter
I love the Jacqueline Hill Becca
champagne collection palette I use the
mix of amaretto and Pamplemousse French
grapefruit blushes sorry I'm on French's
lip crap and then I put some champagne
pulp on top I'm using a real techniques
brush to apply the blush and the
highlighter I used the regular part for
blush and the cypher loominator which
I'm sure is blasphemy but I've been
reassured by true qualified makeup
artists that there are nerve rules and
makeup so but do what I want at this
point I usually realize I've put on too
much blush and blend it out with the
Ecotools brush again I'm not that
skilled at makeup
I'm using Loreal brow artist expert
mechanical brow pencil in Ebony for my
brows for the longest time it was
impossible to find a brow product that
wasn't true red for me but this new
range has greater and browns which is
awesome because it means I don't have to
buy Korean brow products online anymore
my browser micro bladed but there are a
few spots where the pigment didn't
implant well so it's a little bit patchy
mostly I just leaved them because I was
never that good at doing my brows anyway
so my slightly patchy micro bladed brows
are a million times better than my old
brows but I'm putting in effort because
I'm filming I have a really simple i
shadow process I've seen tutorials where
they really gradually put on eye shadow
and it looks amazingly blended and
gorgeous but I'm too impatient for that
I really like sleep so I like my whole
beauty routine to be like 15 minutes
long and most days I don't even use
eyeshadow so this is my quick and dirty
routine I start with a tude house proof
10 eye primer so my eyeshadow sticks on
evenly I usually go for shimmery
eyeshadow because it's a bit more
forgiving and easier to blend I'm using
the shade Venus from the Garbo and Kelly
overnight sensation palette with a real
techniques eyes shadow brush and putting
it all over my lid as the base color
then I use a pencil brush from bdellium
to add a darker shade Pandora and Pat it
on the outside corner then I used the
Real Techniques brush again and blend
the two shades together I use the clean
ish fluffy Bedell and brush to blend the
edge of the eyeshadow and heard that it
looks okay I actually got semi-permanent
eyeliner done recently after using
pencil eyeliner for about 15 years I'm
putting a little extra on here for
filming purposes and because the eye
shadow is covered up a bit but mostly
I've been just going out the door
without doing anything actually I
normally did this anyway because I do my
eyeliner and lipstick on the train I
like my sleep I don't bump anyone I
don't spread myself everywhere
no one gets eyeliner on them I'm quieter
than people talking on the phone just
let me live my life my eyeliner is from
girly cosmetics which is a makeup artist
type branch that has stalls that expose
but doesn't really sell direct I
discovered them by chance and it's been
the first pencil eyeliner that didn't
transfer on my oily lids so I've stuck
by it I'm too scared to change I don't
usually wear mascara a few people have
asked me about this it's because I have
that hair-pulling disorder that I'm
probably going to say wrong
trichotillomania and it usually happens
when I'm stressed which is quite a lot
so my eyelashes are usually too uneven
for mascara to look good once that's
done I miss my face with a setting spray
I'm currently using al Jeunesse splash
which has a really nice fine mist it
makes everything look less powdery and
more like actual human skin and
hopefully keeps it intact a bit more
during the day but I'm super oily so
usually that doesn't happen
today I'm using synergy lip flow in
TIROS I really like this lip gloss it's
more pigmented than the usual lip gloss
but it doesn't clump up it's very sticky
so it stays in place and it's really
moisturizing so that's my morning
routine I hope you found this video
interesting if you liked it and if you
want to find out more about science more
sciency stuff in this video anyway you
can look at my channel which has lots of
videos I've also got my blog which has
lots and lots of posts about beauty
science you can also follow me on
Instagram where I put lots and lots of
science-based beauty tips see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]